rock stars in the house people
yeah the minimalists are with us Joshua
and Ryan famous guys a famous
documentary number one best-selling
books have taught a whole bunch of you
to live with less stuff to have a find a
cure for your stuff itis and they've
also modeled it these guys are amazing
the Netflix documentary is just it's
enthralling and it has done so well
they've been on everything New York
Times Wall Street Journal Boston Globe
Forbes Time ABC CBS all the alphabets
it's all there even NPR so they're there
and they were in town Rachel did their
podcast with them last night Rachel
Cruise one of the rooms your
personalities my daughter did and she
said they're coming over the office you
gotta get them on the air and of course
we gotta get them on the air these guys
are big-time so much Dave yeah what a
dream come true for this Dave thanks so
much for having us man I mean for us man
you guys have been tearing up out there
we're so proud of you and you've helped
so many people approximately 20 million
people have been impacted by this
message by the way if you are a
minimalist follower already which if
you're not that just means you live in a
cave somewhere so get out more you
should get out more but if you're if you
are you want to talk to these guys you
got a question or comment or maybe you
just want tell them things we're gonna
take calls in just a few minutes so the
phone number right now you can get
online and tell Kelly you want to talk
to these guys it's triple 8 8 2 5 5 2 2
5 that's triple 8 8 2 5 5 2 2 5 now I
don't know what percentage of our world
knows every detail about you guys but
it's a bunch the overlap is quite
amazing because we tell people to do
beans and rice rice and beans which is a
form of mentalism minimalism you know
lower your lifestyle
stop your spending so you got money to
get out of that and that intersects with
your all's message so much that a ton of
our tribes your tribe and my tribe
intersect don't they there's a ton of
overlap I mean I think you are talking
about the same thing that Josh and I are
talking about and that's really about
how can we control these impulses that
we have on the daily basis and when we
let these impulses run amok especially
with our finances we can find ourselves
the world of hurt so I mean for Josh and
I you know our our main mission really
is to help people realize well a couple
things a you don't need nearly as much
is what the advertisements to tell you
that you need and that you can be
content without chasing that that status
quo American Dream and really once
someone feels like they have enough when
they when they feel secure enough that's
when they start to look outward and
that's when they start to see what they
can do for their community what they can
do for their friends and family and
that's that's the one thing we really
love about you all is is giving is I
mean in every in every dollar out that's
the first line item that you have you
suggest people budget for is giving and
ultimately Josh and I were trying to
help people be content enough to where
they feel like they can they can give
beyond themselves in a meaningful way
and you have that contentment is a big
deal 25 years ago when we started
teaching this stuff we told people then
and it's still true today we live in the
most marketed to culture in the history
of the world and marketing in and of
itself is not evil right but the very
essence of marketing including when
you're selling a book or I'm selling a
book is the to plant some level of
dissatisfaction discontentment until I
get that item or the I what the items
gonna bring me and then I feel or the
experience it doesn't amount to be an
item it could be a vacation but but when
I get that then I'm supposed to be okay
and the problem is the messages are
exceeding the gathering of these things
and there's no way that we don't live in
the most discontented culture so I think
that's what you guys are tapped into and
it just comes in some congratulations
thank you so how do y'all man
yes why would you think about day we
receive over 5,000 advertisements a day
I mean that's over a million a year so
tell people that don't know for the
uninitiated
what is minimalism so the way I think
about minimalism is it's the thing that
gets us past the things so we can make
room for life's most important things
which actually aren't things at all the
average American household has more than
three hundred thousand items in it and
that's not me going around counting
other people's stuff that's LA Times
reported that a few years ago and it's
not that things are inherently bad or
evil just say you talked about marketing
when marketing is done really well
you're being polite and saying ham I
have a solution to a problem that you
already have we do kind of a problem
when we moved when I was a kid one of
the boxes you know your label the boxes
you packed stuff in yes was labeled
seldom-used kitchen items actually get
in the way of what a more meaningful
life can be we do we make these
aspirational purchases like all that
look really great on that mannequin or
that car look really great in that ad I
think it's gonna add value to my life
but is it really going to add value so
for me minimalism was a way for me to
figure out what are the things that are
truly gonna add value to my life that
amplify that augment my experience of
life and then get rid of those things
that are just in the way what is that
excess that I mean I look at our items
as they're they're three different types
of items there are the essentials we all
have the same basic essentials right we
we all need clothing and shelter and
food and then there are non essentials
the things that truly add value to our
lives things that will make our life
better when we have them and there's the
third category and that is junk that is
the seldom used kitchen items right and
seldom use actually means just in case I
think those are the three most dangerous
words in the English language right it
means I'm gonna hold on to these just in
case I might need them someday and some
line it's a line of somebody that has
the psychological disorder of hoarding
hoarding yeah yeah use that same line
and in a sense we all have a little bit
that disorder in this culture don't well
I wasn't just in case I was a
well-organized hoarder and so yeah I
wasn't a candidate for the TV show
because all of my stuff we're on all of
these bins and boxes and ordinal
alphabetized system of stuff that was
never gonna use in my basement in my
second living room in my attic all of
these things I built this mausoleum of
stuff called a suburban house and and
decided well I think these things are
gonna make me happy well maybe the next
thing will make me happy maybe the next
thing but of course you get that next
thing and the the ephemeral pleasure it
doesn't last far past the checkout line
and it turns out the VHS collection
probably ain't gonna work
some day just in case the cassette
collection the Hubble is just not gonna
work I know that's right but so what led
you to into this I know the story but
I'll throw you their hand pinch it kind
of start with Mia
we both grew up really poor in Dayton
Ohio so just right up the road here in
Dayton and you know we we thought we
were so unhappy because we didn't have
any money growing up I was on food
stamps and government assistance and and
there was alcohol and drug abuse in the
household a lot of bad decisions and and
the reason we were so discontented it
had to be because there was no money so
when I went out I turned 18 I got the
entry-level corporate job and I spent
the next decade climbing the corporate
ladder and by my late twenties I had
achieved everything I ever wanted
six-figure salary the luxury cars plural
I don't know what the plural of Lexus is
but I had all the stuff the closets full
of really expensive clothes that I sell
them more and and all of these things
but of course with that American Dream
came my version which was the American
debt I made really good money but I
spent even better money and that wasn't
a dream at all I realized this was
someone else's dream that they had
conjured up for me and this template
wasn't necessarily working anymore
the minimalist are our guests Joshua and
Ryan this half-hour if you want to talk
there phone the phone number is triple
eight eight to five five two to five
Kelly's keeping the lines open just for
you guys to jump in to have a chance to
talk to them if you haven't seen the
documentary be sure you look it up if
you haven't followed them on social you
should the mental minimalist comma lead
you to everything you want very highly
rated podcast and you can see why we're
going to talk more in this next segment
coming up stick with us this is a Dave
Ramsey show
[Music]
Joshua and Ryan join us the minimalist
for this half-hour if you want to talk
to him the phone numbers triple eight
eight two five five two two five so
Joshua was telling his story he was
doing the corporate ladder gathered up
all the stuff and the stuff doesn't do
it for you you buy enough stuff it just
more stuff and I tell people all the
time you know if lobster just tastes
like soap you know there's only so much
of this stuff you can do right and then
it reaches a point of satiation in your
psychology and it doesn't it just
doesn't do anymore you figure out you
know there is no Ryder truck following a
hearse this stuff is not going to do it
so what was your story then right how'd
you get here so for me you know it's
weird Dave if you were to have told my
18 year old self
well my 28 year old self was going to
have I would have been the most excited
eighteen year old like wow I'm gonna I'm
gonna be buying a new car well you know
borrowing money to buy a new I'm gonna
be able to buy a new car every couple
years I'm gonna I'm gonna be able to get
a 2,000 square foot home with with two
living rooms I'm gonna have a you know a
good job at a respectable corporation
and I'm gonna be so happy and I I did
have everything that I ever wanted at 28
years old but I didn't have happiness I
had a lot of discontent I had a lot of
debt I was I was miserable and I didn't
really know which way was up and I
remember seeing Josh make these changes
in his life over several months to the
point where he started making I remember
the really really cut my attentions he
started giving our boss rules when our
boss was allowed to contact him hey man
I'm not gonna answer my phone after nine
o'clock if it's Christmas Eve it's 6
p.m. and I'm out to dinner I'm gonna
ignore your call because it's Christmas
Eve and I'm spending time with friends
or I'm spending time with family and
that type of talk was kind of
sacrilegious what are you doing like
what is going on with you man why are
you so happy
and that's when he introduced this thing
called minimalism to me and not only
that he showed me a whole community of
people who called themselves minimalists
and it was a wide range of people there
was a guy named Colin Wright who was
traveling the world carrying everything
he owned on his back I like having a
kitchen tape
so that wasn't like the most appealing
life but then there's guy named leo but
bhauja he had eight I'm sorry he had six
kids him and his wife living out in San
Francisco there was a gal named Courtney
Carver she was living in Salt Lake City
with her teenage daughter but what I
realize is that there are these people
living meaningful lives and they're
using this thing called minimalism to do
it so I got really excited I looked at
Joshua said alright man I'm in I'm gonna
be a minimalist now what I didn't really
know where to start you get rid of your
stuff right so we started with I didn't
want to spend several months packing up
like Josh had I mean that was a great
approach for him but I you know I just
needed some faster results
typical American attitude right so we
came up with this crazy idea called a
packing party where we decided to pack
all my belongings as if I were moving
and then I would unpack only the items I
needed over the next three weeks so Josh
came over and he literally helped me box
up everything my clothes and kitchenware
my towels my TV's my electronics my
frame photographs and paintings my
toiletries and even my furniture
everything we literally pretended like I
was moving so after you know three weeks
of unpacking you can imagine those first
things I'm unpacking some clothes for
work toothbrush and toiletries well
after those three weeks I had 80% of my
stuff still sitting in those boxes just
sitting there on accessed and I had this
huge just light bulb moment about how I
have spent this past you know decade of
my life accumulating tens of thousands
of dollars worth of things to make me
happy and they were not doing their job
so I decided to donate and sell all of
it and that's really where the
minimalists dot-com started it was with
that twenty one day packing party story
and and what happens I think with people
that are following you guys is that some
of them do it by degrees and that they
just limit yeah they take their life and
just cut it some yeah and so that's the
level of influence and then some of them
go down further than you
like for instance I revel in the world
that's in the documentary that you
mentioned he's down to just two bags of
stuff and his on the shoulders alright
everything is on his rack yeah at one
point you were like 288 items you were
yeah yeah just those sort of uh
I realized that
there was this weird sort of competition
going on in this this whole minimalism
space where I was like because I think
minimalism is not about deprivation
right that's what I was getting towards
because if that's a contest I'm not
going to win because I saw one guy who
owned 50 items and someone else is like
well no I own 45 and there's someone
else who owns 15 and eventually when you
just naked running in the street if you
can to my house right now
you know we have a five-year-old
daughter so my life looks appreciably
different now at age 37 than when I was
28 and I first discovered minimalism and
so you came to our house now you
wouldn't say oh my goodness
this guy's a minimalist you probably
just walk in and say wow they're they're
pretty tidy this family oh they're
simple yeah simple living yeah it's cuz
we don't know much but everything we do
own adds real value to our lives each of
our belongings like my car my clothes my
kitchen where my furniture has a
function it changes the way you purchase
something yeah looking at it like oh
really
what's the real cost of this because
sometimes there's a price tag the price
tag says it's widgets $100 but what does
it also cost to fuel the thing to change
the oil that thing replaced the
batteries and the things store the thing
clean the thing the more stuff you own
the more repairman you have to know yes
and then it ends up owning you yeah
how's that how's that very cool all
right let's jump on the phones and see
who's out there
looks like Kansas City's calling in and
Elizabeth is with us hey Elizabeth your
question for Joshua and Ryan hey there
hey Dave I just want to say thanks for
all that you do and I'm so excited that
Brian and Josh are talking about this
this is so needed in our society I'm a
single mom
and I wanted to know I have two kids a
10 year old and a 15 year old their
father is very successful attorneys and
gives and gives all kinds of fun
expensive gifts and they're actually
going on in a trip right now overseas
you got Disney dad in the
how can I influence my kids towards
minimalism and wholeness it doesn't come
from things what do you guys think about
that
you know I first embraced minimalism I
had this pivot point my mother died my
marriage ended both in the same month
and these two events forced me to look
around and start to question what had
become my life's focus and Elizabeth I
realized that I was focused on the wrong
stuff and so when I started to simplify
my life tell me about eight months I
radically simplified people around me
started noticing something was different
Ryan came to me said hey what the heck
are you so happy lately people at work
site were saying you see my stress you
seem so much calmer why why aren't you
being as mean as he used to be and it
opened up the door for me to talk about
this thing because I never jumped up and
said look at me I'm becoming a
minimalist then you need to - it's not
about the proselytizing of minimalism
it's about showing people what the
benefits are so I always start with a
question how might your life be better
with less and we do that with our five
year old daughter right now also how
might your life be better if you're
giving instead of just taking all the
time so I think whether it's we're
dealing with adults or kids we have to
talk about one of the benefits of
simplifying for you because I think
they're different for each of us for me
it was just finances at first but then
it was a rediscovering time for my
creativity and and for other values in
my life that were important but one of
the but one of the benefits for you
Elizabeth and then what are the benefits
for your kids you know just talk it
through with them and you just the thing
is what do you what what do you how do
you define what's important mmm yeah
that's part of it in it yeah absolutely
it's just you know we're redefining
what's important yeah the gathering of
stuff is not what's important right and
it's not it's not a lack of stuff no it
doesn't have to be that you you know
you're not a bad minimalist if you have
over 104 items I mean you can't there's
not a mark that it's it's a mindset that
says stuff is not where I'm gonna draw
my happiness stuff is not where I'm
gonna draw my meaning is that right
exactly I'm so glad you bring that up
because the packing party you're right
like me packing up my stuff and being
confronted with 80% of my possessions it
wasn't your right it wasn't the packing
up
of the stuff it wasn't getting rid of
the 80% of stuff that that was freeing
what was spraying is reprioritizing what
my priorities were because up until that
point if you would have asked me hey
Ryan what are your priorities I would I
said well my health that's a major
priority but I was eating fast food
every day my finances I want to retire
but I was spending money and all that
stuff yeah and what I realized is my
priorities it's not what I say I do it's
what I actually do Joshua and Ryan
thanks for hanging out the minimalist
man it's been possible we are we're
slightly cooler than we were a few
minutes ago for having us hey you guys
check out their podcast the minimal it's
just one of the top podcasts in the
world mimic the minimalist dot-com for
all the information you need I follow
them on Twitter you can check all of
their stuff out check the best-selling
books out you won't be sorry you did
this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]